es el país de la pura vida y es conocido
por haber sido uno de los más seguros de
América Latina sin embargo la
inseguridad aumenta en Costa Rica una
bala perdida mató en febrero a Samuel
Arroyo de ocho años esto provocó la
indignación Popular
podríamos andar tranquilos hasta ciertas
horas pero ya eso es diferente ha
aumentado mucho la violencia los asaltos
sin importarles que una bala puede herir
a un inocente en 2022 Costa Rica
registró su récord de homicidios con 657
están surgiendo bandas criminales
locales formadas por gente muy joven el
país ha pasado de ser un lugar de paso
para el narcotráfico a ser un punto de
almacenamiento y transbordo de drogas
hacia Europa de eso de comienzos son en
su mayoría a miembros de estructuras
criminales a gatilleros o sicarios o a
personas que tienen algún rol importante
dentro de esas estructuras
ante la búsqueda de soluciones el
ministro de seguridad ha elogiado el
método bukele Mientras que el canciller
fue más cauto en palabras a France 24
durante la Cumbre iberoamericana
nosotros no tenemos un estado de
excepción como en El Salvador Aunque sí
reconocemos que se han incrementado
algunos puntos de inseguridad en el país
sobre todo el asesinato entre bandas de
narcotraficantes es un punto focal que
merece nuestra atención y estamos
haciendo todo esfuerzo para combatirlas
dentro del marco del estado de derecha
Costa Rica ha tenido históricamente una
perspectiva de seguridad relajada sin un
ejército permanente pero la situación
podría cambiar